I turned 19 that summer and Uganda
[Music]
so I the chance to work for a consulting
firm after graduation and make lots of
money
but I knew that this is where it alone
[Music]
I came to Uganda in 2010 to teach at an
all-girls Academy and I was living with
the host family there getting sick all
the time because they were drinking
dirty water I was getting sick all the
time too and I think that was actually
kind of the aha moment
[Music]
10,000 people died in Uganda every year
drinking dirty water
[Music]
diarrheal diseases remain the second
leading cause of death for children
under the age of five access to clean
drinking water is a basic human right
and it seems stupid to not have a
solution for it I had an engineering
background and I thought given the
abundance of clay ceramic water filters
are a great fit for Uganda you take
sawdust clay and then you grind them
into really small pieces add water and
you get this mass
then we just press it using a mold and
then they are put into the kiln fired up
till 900 degrees and the Saudis combust
leaving behind microscopic pores it's a
really simple process that uses physical
filtration to allow bacteria to stay up
top and the water to go down
I took the design and I approached a
bunch of local organizations and every
single one of them Terry down and so
then I was like alright well no one's
gonna do it then I'm gonna do it thank
you
hi everyone I'm Kathy I'm John we
started out in the middle of nowhere in
eastern Uganda
living with no running water dirt floors
I got bin by rat once it was the
constant trouble try to figure out
whether or not this is actually gonna
work and you start asking like why am I
here it took three of us the entire day
just to make ten filters at our new site
we can make 10,000 filters a month
you're not just impacting the 25 people
who are making the filters you have to
think about where we get our clay from
where we get our other raw materials
from because we do it locally is
impacted by the work that we're doing
we have provided a hundred thousand
people with access to clean drinking
water there's still much more to do I
want to filter in every single household
in Uganda I think in the next couple of
months I can go to school while our team
continues to grow it's important for me
to leave because I want to be able to go
out and try something new in pop or
lives but I want to see where that
potential leads me I wonder what I can
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you